[__] is an Aztec word that means to be
happy not after this one oh that smells
horrible give me a smell oh oh that hurt
me nose just smell it it burnt my tongue
smelling it
all right let's get it all in there Jack
you're sweating a little I feel like a
winner
yeah okay
I know what it is but I've never heard
you say that that's an Al Pacino X
takes a bit of chili yeah you said it
worse it's gotten worse isn't it gotten
worse wow you've got a glistened here
you're gonna be famous now Jack how many
chips do we buy four reckon you could do
two yeah all right get another one out
wait you gonna do another one yeah what
am I a [__] yeah yeah what is he a
[__] I have to go to a concert tonight
what do you what is it like yeah it's a
little sassiere
oh gross it's great it's gonna tastes
bad yeah it's not gonna tastes bad I
don't feel the heat as much on this this
is the main reason I won't let you suck
my dick today